هذا الشارع كان شاهدا على واقعه مروريه
تعتبر الاغراب من نوعها شغلت الراي العام
تصدرت الاسافير ومنصات محليه وعالميه سائق
متهور يقود سيارته بالخلف رفقه اصدقائه
احتفالا بالتخرج من الجامعه
عبد الحميد الطاهر لم يتمكن من الاستمتاع
بما قام به لوقت اطول فشرطه مرور ولايه
الخرطوم القت عليه القبضه متلبسا بالقياده
بالخلف واعتبر التصرفه مخالفه واضحه
لقواعد المرور الاساسيه وتعطيلا لحركه
السير وخطرا على الطريق والسائق نفسه وصفه
سلوكه بالطيش والتهور وبعد مده قضاها
بالسجن وعقوبه رادعه السائق المتهور عبد
الحميد الطاهر ضيفا على صباح العربيه
اولا الحمد لله على السلامه شغلت الاساطير
ومنصات محليه وعالميه واصبحت ترند بسبب
مقطع تم انتشاره في السوشيال ميديا ما
القصه الله يسلمك يا رب
في جامعه السودان العالميه
يوم 27/12 زفه بتاع التخريج
بتاعه واحد الجيران
المهم الناس انها هي يعني
شغلات يفحيط وانا قلت ارجع اخف كثيرين
يعتبروا انه ما قمت به هو تقليد لفان ديزل
في سلسله افلام
وهو تطبيق لتلك الافلام على ارض الواقع
لكن انا اصلا ما قاعد احضر افلام يعني ما
قلدت نهائيا
يعني
سبحان الله من زمان متعود عليها انه ارجع
للخلف في الحله قاعد ارجع للخلف كثير يعني
في الشوارع برجع لكن ما حصل فيها التصوير
ما تم نشره في المقطع هي مسافه قصيره في
شارع النيل الخرطوم ما المسافه الفعليه
التي قطعتها والله المسافه الحقيقيه هي من
الازهري من جامعه السودان العالميه تحدي
دي مسافه كبيره شديد
كانت حوالي نص ساعه كذا لان نص ساعه انت
سايق خلف
لو قلت احسبيها كيلو مترات يعني حوالي 16
17 كيلو
العقوبه شنو او المده اللي قضيتها بالسجن
والله هو حكموا علي بشهرين
وعملت استرحام شال شهر وعديت جوا السجن
شهر خرجت يوم 25 اثنين وسحبوا الرخصه لمده
عشر سنه عشر
سنوات ما عندك رخصه سنوات ما عندي رخصة
تمتلك مقدرات خارقه
للامانه يعني الموضوع جنوني
هل التوظيفه بشكل صحيح او ايجابي يعني
نتحدث عن الخطط والمشاريع اي والله عندي
فكره كده انه افتح مدرسه ان شاء الله عما
غريب ان شاء الله باذن الله
لتعليم قياده السيارات
شكرا عبد الحميد شكرا صباح العربي شكرا